LET’S MAKE SURE YOU GET DONE
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
JUDGE JEANINE: THANK YOU WE
SALUTE YOU AS WELL THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE WITH US
TONIGHT.
JOINING US TONIGHT IS HOUSING
AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT AND ALSO
PART OF THE WHITE HOUSE IS
DOCTOR BEN CARSON.
IT’S GOOD TO TALK TO DOCTOR, I
WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN IN THE
NEWS FOR THE LAST FEW DAYS,
AND THAT IS THE WHOLE IDEA OF
THE HYDRA OKAY WHAT WHAT IS
THAT THAT IS HYDROXYQUINOLINE
NZ PACK.
I REALIZE THIS DOESN’T HAVE
FDA APPROVAL FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO NOW HAVE THE CORONAVIRUS,
BUT IS IT AVAILABLE FOR THOSE
WHO WANT TO BE ABLE TO USE IT
UNTIL WE GET TO THE POINT
WHERE WE HAVE A CURE OR AT
LEAST A VACCINE?
>> THESE ARE PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS.
THAT THEY HAVE UTILIZED FOR
MANY, MANY YEARS.
WITH HYDROXYQUINOLINE, IT HAS
BEEN USED FOR MALARIA FOR
DECADES.
BUT IT HAS NOT BEEN USED IN
THIS PARTICULAR CONTEXT.
I THINK THAT IS WHERE THERE’S
BEEN GOING BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT ENTRANCE ONE AND
THERE’S REALLY NO ROOM FOR A
FIGHT BECAUSE SIMPLY BECAUSE
DOCTOR FAUCI IS SAYING WE
DON’T HAVE THE DATA TO PROVE
OVER THE LONG-TERM THAT THIS
IS EFFECTIVE AND TOTALLY SAFE
IN THIS SETTING.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING,
YOU KNOW BY THE TIME WE GET
THAT DATA, IT WILL BE TOO LATE
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE.
WE KNOW THAT IT HAS BEEN USED
IN SETTING SAFELY.
LET’S MAYBE TAKE A LITTLE MORE
RISK, BECAUSE WE GET A LOT
MORE UPSIDE.
AND THAT SORT OF THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A BUSINESS
PERSON AND A SCIENTIST.
WITH A SCIENTIST EVERYTHING
HAS TO BE, AND WITH THE
BUSINESS PERSON IT’S WING THIS
VERSUS THAT.
JUDGE JEANINE: IT’S REALLY A
BENEFIT.
IF YOU GO THROUGH ALL THE
PHASES OF REVIEW, THE PERSON
WHO HAS THE VIRUS COULD BE
DEAD.
SO GIVEN THE ADMINISTRATION
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP ONCE TO
TRY, THIS IS NOW SOMETHING
THERE’S A CERTAIN COMPASSION
ABILITY TO GET THIS STUFF.
LET’S TALK ABOUT WHEN YOU
THINK, DOCTOR WENDY THINK WE
WILL GET TO THE PEAK OF THIS?
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA?
>> WE HAVE AN IDEA BASED ON
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN OTHER
COUNTRIES.
IT IS A REASONABLE ASSUMPTION
WE WOULD HAVE THE SAME KIND OF
THINGS HAPPENING HERE.
WE ARE PROBABLY LOOKING AT
MONTHS, HOPEFULLY A COUPLE
VERSUS SEVERAL.
BUT SOMEWHERE IN THAT RANGE.
OF COURSE THINGS ARE BETTER
BECAUSE WE’RE TREATING THIS
VERY AGGRESSIVELY.
AS YOU HAVE NOTED IN SOME
PLACES, THERE WASN’T AN
AGGRESSIVE PUSH BACK.
AND HENCE YOU SEE AN
INCREASE.
WE HAVE SOME PLACES LIKE THAT
IN OUR COUNTRY, LIKE NEW YORK
CITY, WASHINGTON, AND IT
WASN’T BECAUSE THEY DIDN’T
PUSH BACK, THEY HAD A LOT OF
PEOPLE COMING INTO THOSE AREAS
FROM OUTSIDE THE COUNTRY AND
THE PLACES WHERE THE CONTACT
HAD BEEN MADE.
JUDGE JEANINE: DOCTOR, I WANT
TO MOVE ON TO YOUR POSITION IS
THE HEAD OF HUD.
I WANT TO LET MY VIEWERS KNOW
WHAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
DOING WITH THE MORATORIUM ON
FORECLOSURES CAN YOU EXPLAIN
THAT TO MY VIEWERS?
>> WHAT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING THAT PEOPLE HAVE
FINANCIALLY FOR THEIR HOME?
WHILE THEY ARE BEING TERRIFIED
AND TRYING TO KEEP THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILY SAFE, THE
LAST THING WE WANT THEM TO
WORRY ABOUT IS WHETHER THEY’RE
GOING TO LOSE THEIR HOUSE.
BECAUSE OF PAYMENTS THAT A
BEEN LAGGING.
SO THE PRESIDENT AUTHORIZED US
TO GO AHEAD AND PLACE A 60 DAY
MORATORIUM ON FORECLOSURES AND
EVICTIONS THAT WERE IN
PROGRESS AS WELL AS THOSE THAT
MAY OCCUR OVER THE NEXT 60
DAYS.
JUDGE JEANINE: WILL THERE BE A
REINVESTMENT DOCTOR?
I ONLY HAVE A FEW SECONDS LEFT
BUT PEOPLE HAVE TROUBLE PAYING
THEIR MORTGAGE WHERE THERE IS
NO FORECLOSURE, WHAT IS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OFFERING?
>> WE ASKED BEFORE ENGINE
FORBEARANCE FOR THE SERVICES
WE WANT THEM TO LOOK AT THE
WHOLE CASCADE OF OPTIONS THAT
THEY HAVE BEFORE THEY WOULD
EVEN THINK ABOUT EVICTION OR
FORECLOSURE.
JUDGE JEANINE: OKAY SO I GUESS
IT’S UP TO CONGRESS TO PASS
THE FORBEARANCE, CORRECT?
>> WHEN IT COMES TO THE PHA’S,
THE PUBLIC HOUSING AUTHORITY
AND PEOPLE ON SECTION EIGHT,
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO RESTRICT
THEM FROM DOING EVICTIONS
WOULD REQUIRE CONGRESS TO ACT
AND WE HAVE ASKED THEM TO DO
THAT QUITE FRANKLY.
BUT I DON’T THINK YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS WITH THAT BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT INTERESTED IN
THROWING PEOPLE OUT.